manchmal kleben Sie die Schilder ab der
Feind soll die Orientierung verlieren
denn einige russische Einheiten so heißt
es hätten keine modernen
Navigationsgeräte
von with dem ehemaligen Lemberg fahren
wir Richtung Nordosten unser erstes Ziel
ist die atomstadt wahrasch das
Kernkraftwerk rivene liegt nur wenige
Kilometer von der belarussischen Grenze
entfernt
[Musik]
die Ukraine hat fünf Kernkraftwerke zwei
davon sind schon von russischen Truppen
besetzt das stillgelegte in Tschernobyl
und das Kernkraftwerk in saporiska
werden die Russen auch die Anlage in
Riesner besetzen der stellvertretende
Direktor zeigt uns den Kontrollraum im
Trainingszentrum das sein Atomkraftwerk
je durch einen Krieg bedroht werden
könnte war für ihn bis vor kurzem
unvorstellbar
wir werden unsere Kraftwerk verteidigen
mit allem was wir haben genauso wie ihr
eure Kamera verteidigen würdet wenn sie
euch jemand wegnehmen will wenn jemand
verhindern will dass ihr den Job machen
könnt den ihr machen wollt dann würdet
ihr euch auch verteidigen
[Musik]
40.000 Menschen die Mitarbeiter des
Kraftwerks und ihre Familie
ein Denkmal erinnert an die
Atomkatastrophe von Tschernobyl vor 36
Jahren in varasch glauben sie an die
Sicherheit der Atomenergie und wissen
doch dass sie in diesem Krieg auf einem
Pulverfass sitzen
Bürgermeister in Suhl hat sein halbes
Leben in varasch verbracht seine Stadt
sei sicher sagt er vor Angriffen vom
Boden vor Angriffen aus der Luft aber
sei sie es nicht ja wir brauchen
Unterstützung um unseren Luftraum zu
schützen sagt die Raketen fliegen über
unsere Stadt hinweg bis ins Zentrum der
Ukraine sie werden vom Territorium von
Belarus abgefeuert ballistische Raketen
andere Raketentypen
die bombardieren die Ukraine über uns
hinweg und wir können nichts dagegen tun
sie fühlen sich allein gelassen vom
Ausland und so wird der freundliche Mann
plötzlich sehr deutlich
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
und ihr Chef Herr grossi sagen es sei
alles unter Kontrolle aber das ist eine
Lüge ich weiß dass meine Kollegen aus
Tschechien vorgeschlagen haben das
internationale Friedenstruppen der
Vereinten Nationen an den Atomstandorten
stationiert werden sollen natürlich ohne
die Beteiligung Russlands
diese Friedens Truppen zum Schutz ihres
Kraftwerks aber werden sie nicht
bekommen
von warrash aus geht es erstmal wieder
Richtung Süden unser Ziel ist die
Provinzhauptstadt
die Fahrt dorthin dauert sehr viel
länger als gewöhnlich denn alle paar
Kilometer werden wir kontrolliert an
einem der vielen Checkpoints überall
Sandsack Welle Panzer sperren groß ist
die Angst vor russischen Spionen und
sabotteuren
wo früher Werbeplakate hängen stehen
heute durchhalte Parolen unsere Einheit
ist unsere Kraft steht da
in rivener sind wir mit dem Provinz
Gouverneur verabredet seine
Verwaltungszentrale ist ein
Hochsicherheitstrakt
als die Sirenen heulen wird das Treffen
in den Luftschutzkeller verlegt früher
waren Belarus und Ukrainer Brüder sagt
Vitali Koval doch damit sei es nach dem
russischen Einmarsch vorbei
heute feiern sie tödliche Waffen von
Belarus auf uns ab sie haben
Hubschrauber Raketen wir können es uns
nicht leisten entspannt zu sein was die
Frage angeht ob belarussische Soldaten
irgendwann den Fuß in die Ukraine setzen
stellen wir keine Vermutungen an sondern
wir bereiten uns darauf vor
dreieinhalb Auto Stunden sind es von
Rewe nach chipong es ist die
Hauptverkehrsverbindung vom Westen der
Ukraine parallel zur belarussischen
Grenze Richtung Hauptstadt Kiel
wird zur Festung ausgebaut freiwillige
füllen Sandsäcke sichern Gebäude
Kreuzungen jeder der verdächtig
erscheint wird sofort gemeldet und
überprüft denn die Stadt ist ein
Verkehrsknotenpunkt für den Nachschub
Richtung Kiew und damit ein häufiges
Ziel russischer Luftangriffe
hier wurde eine Schule im Zentrum der
Stadt von einer Rakete getroffen und
fast völlig zerstört die Tommy liegt
rund 150 km westlich der Hauptstadt Kiew
die seit Wochen von russischen Truppen
belagert wird das heißt hier ist man
sehr viel näher an den Kämpfen als in
vielen anderen Städten im Westen der
Ukraine und deshalb hat fast die Hälfte
der Bevölkerung die Stadt bereits
verlassen
als Anfang März Raketen neben dem
Krankenhaus einschlugen wurden viele
Patienten evakuiert und einige
Abteilungen ins Untergeschoss verlegt
seitdem wurden hier im Keller 60 Kinder
geboren
Adelina ist drei Tage alt sie kam zu
früh auf die Welt zu groß waren die
Schrecken des Krieges für die junge
Mutter
ich habe Angst ich weiß nicht was als
nächstes kommen wird auch jetzt wieder
fliegen die Raketen ich weiß nicht wie
es mit mir weitergehen soll und vor
allem was mit meinem kleinen Mädchen
passieren wird sie hat gesundheitliche
Probleme das alles macht mir sehr große
Angst
im Rathaus hinter Sandsäcken regiert
Bürgermeister Sergej suchomlin seine
Stadt früher wollte er kein Bild eines
ukrainischen Präsidenten über seinem
Schreibtisch haben die reden nur und tun
nichts meinte so homlin stattdessen
sendete Mahatma Gandhi seine Botschaft
der Gewaltlosigkeit doch jetzt musste
Gandhi weichen
Argumente funktionieren hier und heute
leider nicht mehr es ist die Zeit zu den
Waffen zu greifen uns bleibt keine
andere Wahl und Präsident selenski hat
sich als wahrer Anführer des Landes
gezeigt
der Feind so ist so homlin überzeugt
wird nicht nachgeben auch wenn Präsident
Putin gelegentlich sagt er sei bereit
für Kompromisse
kurz darauf tritt eine gute Bekannte in
sein Büro Tatjana czornovoy kennt in der
Ukraine jeder sie war Aktivistin der
maidan-proteste war streitbare
Parlamentsabgeordnete Russen töteten
ihren Mann 2014 im Kampf um die Krim
damals beschloss Tatjana Soldatin zu
werden heute ist die Offizierin der
Panzerabwehr
ich bleibe in meiner Stellung so lange
wie nötig die Bilder aus dem Wald die
ich euch gezeigt habe da lagen wir drei
Tage lang in derselben Position ohne
Heizung ohne Feuer wir haben drei Tage
lang nur dort gelegen und haben auf die
Panzer gewartet
dann zeigt sie uns ein Video ihres
letzten Einsatzes vor wenigen Tagen
ins Visier die Rakete wird abgeschossen
und fliegt sie fliegt eine ganze Zeit
der Panzer dreht ab und versucht zu
fliehen aber
kein Panzer mehr
wieder ertönen die Sirenen alle müssen
runter ins Erdgeschoss hinter die
Sandsäcke hinter die dicken Mauern des
alten Rathauses es ist die Routine eines
Krieges eines Krieges für die gerechte
Sache sagte Tiana
ich bin eine von denen die verhindern
dass sie das tun aber ich will euch eins
sagen ich verteidige nicht nur Kiew oder
die Ukraine nicht mal nur Europa wir
verteidigen die ganze Welt
alle die wir auf unserer Reise trafen
fürchten das Präsident Putin bereits
sein könnte zum Äußersten zu gehen er
könnte Bela russische Truppen auf sie
hetzen und ihre Atomkraftwerke
beschießen doch sie würden weiter
kämpfen für die Freiheit ihrer Ukraine